بئر الاسرار المفضوحه قد يهز ثقه الحلفاء
بالولايات المتحده وقدرتها على الاحتفاظ
بمعلومات حساسه في خزانه سريه
تسريب الوثائق التي فاق عددها المئه وفق
ضابط استخبارات عسكري بريطاني متقاعد يثبت
فشلا امريكيا على اعلى مستوى مضيفا ان
الضرر لن يتحدد حجمه على الفور فيما بشرت
وزاره العاده للتحقيقاتها لمعرفه كيفيه
التسريب المواد المصنفه سريه للغايه الا
ان اصابع الاتهام توجهت تلقائيا الى روسيا
او عناصر مواليه لها دون اعطاء المزيد من
التفاصيل
التسريب الاستخباراتي وصفته صحيفه
ديليجراف بالاسوء منذ قضيه ادوارد ايس
نودن من هو هذا الشخص وما قضيته
عمل كمتقاعد متعاقد عفوا مع وكاله الامن
القومي قبل ان يسرب تفاصيل برنامج التجسس
باسم الذي يهدف لمراقبه ملايين المواطنين
الامريكيين الى الصحافه في يونيو
هرب الى موسكو عاش فيها لاجئ سياسي منذ
عشر سنوات اي بعد التسريب وقد منحته روسيا
جنسيتها العمل الماضي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات